there is an inherent attraction to light
and being human and I think on a very
deep psychological level light is this
way in which we experience the energy
surroundings in a very personal matter
my name is Matt Dillon I'm the founder
of light bright neon studio and we
manufacture produce and restore neon
works of Art and Design orange is the
creative content of a lot of the work at
light bright comes from a variety of
sources sometimes people come with a
napkin sketch some people come with
Adobe Illustrator file and we have a
whole design team then we kind of work
together to help create layouts of what
it might look like scale it up and
create a paper template using a pen
plotter and that paper template actually
becomes our guide for what we're going
to bend the neon to we take from the
office into the class shop we pick out
the right size tubing with the right
color for the right science project
from there we heat up the glass tubing
the torches heat the glass well in
excess of a thousand degrees in order
for it to get into its molten state we
heat up and bend the glass tubing to
match the template one of our
chandeliers has over a hundred different
bends in it so each one of those bends
has to be marked for a heated up then we
also have to allow the glass to cool
between the bends so that the next area
can be worked on and heated up in its
own unique fashion it turns into
spaghetti and then we have to make sure
that that spaghetti lines back up and
cools to the template we use a blow hose
to connect our mouth to the tube create
a volume that's closed and we can
control the pressure in there with my
mouth there's just a variety of
challenges that come up inherently in
working with glass glass can crack due
to stress and sometimes you'll just have
a batch that all it wants to do when it
gets near a torch is craft
[Music]
after we've bent various components we
have to go in using the cross layer the
hand torch and actually well - all of
those pieces together the last step on
that is then to weld on electrodes onto
either end
each one of those steps is very very
specific I draw inspiration from so many
different experiences it's hard to come
up with one thing that's particularly
one of the ways that I really am able to
connect with the creative is to float
[Music]
floating is a similar experience to
meditation to psychedelics going into a
blackened room and laying out in a body
of water and salt that's ceded to your
body temperature and it allows for all
sort of external stimulation to fall
away
and you're in eternal world really
begins to bubble up and manifest you
really get to experience a different
relationship to your mind
[Music]
I think I work with neon because I can't
not work with me it's so challenging and
so rewarding and those things are so
intertwined that there's no way of
separating
[Music]
we learn so much and continue to learn
so much by working with it I find so
much inspiration and working with it and
I just continue to experience new and
different things through the medium it's
that close to me
[Music]
once the neon tube is completed we have
to hook it up to our manifold for
bombarding the manifold is open the
vacuum is drawn we check the tube for
leaks with our Tesla coil we close the
tube back off and we heat it up using a
very large and powerful transformer as
the tube is heated up it releases
anything that's not an earth inside the
tube and we evacuate that out we
introduce the gas into it can we seal
the tube off sealing into that tube
whatever gas we introduced into it I
think my favorite part of making any
unlight is when I see it lit up for the
first time differ gases when electrified
emit different wavelengths of light neon
gas is this very bright orange fiery red
color argon gas creates a very intense
blue but that light output that is
produced can then be expressed in a
different wavelength by coating the
inside of the tubes with a phosphor
coating that takes out one wavelength of
light and emits a different wavelengths
we bring it over to the aging table
where we hook it up to an agent
transformer and allow it to settle age
the gas in that we've entered
to it there's always a stray particle of
something left inside the tube but that
time that the oxide coating can act to
scrub whatever is left inside the tube
while things are getting something once
the tubes are aged in we move on to our
process of assembling two halves of the
fixture together in a jig blowing up the
center of the fixture to its spindle
once the adhesive dried we would connect
the wires from the fixture together into
a transformer and we turn on the power
that lights on part of what we love
about what we do here is that we try and
put out into the world the kind of
things that we'd like to see I still am
surprised when it lights up I'm still
excited when I get to see it illuminated
there's an ephah double quality to it to
me is this insight into the inner
workings of the universe it literally is
it's a way of looking at what is
surrounding us in the cosmos in a new
light
[Applause]
you
you